we thought it was very important to
listen to the voice of poets and writers
writers about this eve
and as we
very important because eric oxena who is
a
um as a writer he's a member of the
academy and he's also a sailor and
navigator and he has sent us some words
which showed the commitment to the young
generations throughout the world i'd
like to
welcome yes you are
south africa welcome i'd also like to
lorenzo
italian
hello lorenzo good morning
you are french and european i like your
neighbors
ambassadors of the ocean
from the foundations
to listen to what their commitments are
and perhaps to complete their
commitments eric ocena now
own isolated
no invitation it would have been
irritated to be in this place
because uh it was not able to buy it
but don't you realize
it takes
the time to
uh
[Music]
how essential they are to try to
to heal us and then the second one
epidemic i'm sorry which has uh affected
us if we can learn any lesson perhaps
we have got to learn about health we've
got to learn from the oceans and from
life and everyone knows that the
pollution of the seas is
first and most foremost it comes from
rivers
it's the river waste
and so the responsibility comes from us
from earthlings we must to get together
we must get together and why not meet
here
it's not just words that the ocean wants
the worshian
the ocean
doesn't care at all doesn't give a fig
for words
to see
actions
sometimes can become angry so listen
carefully to what its waves say to us
if
ladies and gentlemen noble ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't come along with
actions as well
have come
and so many of you have you come
in such luxurious uh coaches
to return to breast and to go back to
your palaces and just leave the ocean to
flow as it does
today in bristol in
if you decide nothing or if having made
a decision you don't apply the decisions
you don't commit to them because you
will overcome too late
why but why do we allow this treasure to
soil its resources so immense and so
diverse
yet we the generations to come
will be deprived of it
if nothing
nothing is done to protect them
[Music]
how without the ocean how will we feed
ourselves how can we dream
how can we exchange views and how can we
live without the ocean
why
do we
ignore this friend in fact more than a
friend because it gave birth to us
and we say
we
must
fight any uh
any things which which disrupt the
environment we have so much to learn to
teach us
a free
man you will still
uh cherish the
sea and the ocean
at this time
mid february to 2022 will remain in
history
for the best but it may also be for the
worst so ladies and gentlemen
over to you
over to you and to us
to take a step and
take action now
oh
thank you very much olivier
[Applause]
yes i'm a deepsea biologist that means i
get to dive to the great depths of the
oceans and discover new life that no one
has seen before and polar researcher
means i get to go to the north pole look
under the eyes discover
for me one of the
greatest findings of sciences that
soon after the oceans formed life
emerged
life unicellular life that eventually
learned how to make the oxygen that we
breathe
and eventually became symbions of the
algae and the plants we know plants that
were enabled by the ocean to go to land
and cover land
that's amazing and today we are studying
the genes of these original unicellular
forms because they hold the secret of
how to make hydrogen from sea water with
sunlight
but
did you know
that there are
billions of unknown lifeboards
unicellular lifeforms who we don't know
that don't have a name whose genes we
have not discovered
and do you realize and what do you do
with that scientific fact
that we know that marine life the
diversity in the oceans is declining at
a faster pace than the terrestrial life
it's incredible by that effect
and do you realize that our research
shows
that the warming of the oceans the heat
waves we have in our ocean endangers the
eggs and the larvae of fish of 60
percent of the fish we know and almost
all the fish that we eat
what do we do with those scientific
facts
science is there of course to alert us
science is there to show such problems
to highlight what we have to do to
predict the future but it is also there
to make us dream
but here i would like to voice the
message of this one ocean summit to tell
you that what we see even from spaces
that by now 60 of the calls have leached
and by the end of the century if you
don't change our path it will be all of
them
we have to speak about the fact
that kelp mangrove sea grass is
declining faster than we
destroy rainforest and we cannot afford
any of that because not only do these
ecosystems host an immense diversity
they are our solution they are the
ecosystems that remove co2 from the
atmosphere so actually have to restore
them rather than utilize them destroy
them
so what do we say here at the one ocean
summit we call for more ambition we call
for the protection of the oceans and we
would like to make you aware that
research science must be a partner in
this what you protect you need to know
it you need to understand how it's doing
if we have policies if we have managed
protected areas we still want to know if
the policies work and how do we do that
by science by research and for that we
call you to provide us with an ocean
infrastructure to provide us with an
ability to share data to provide that
information to everyone on earth to
teach the kids that they can be part of
our future
so let me end here by saying one
important point again and again of
course we know little about the oceans
they are like a foreign planet in planet
earth but we know enough to act that
must be very clear and i'll end with one
other wonders of the oceans that i would
like you to take home as an idea
scientists from my institute have
recently discovered under the eyes of
the vidalia in antarctica
that 60 million fish in an area as large
as malta meet
to dive together to 500 meters depth and
build nests and lay eggs and root them
together as if they were chicken think
about that how do they even know that
the others are there and would like to
lay eggs
it's amazing so apparently they know a
moment when it's time to dedicate
everything to the next generation and
what if that here this room would just
have such a fair time moment right now
if all of us
would take home the idea
that we provide for the next generation
with science with infrastructure with
action thank you very much
mercier
thank you very much auntie but
um president of the republic after the
sciences
ladies and gentlemen heads of state and
government welcome to brest
we are very proud not only to welcome
you here in this city
to make collective commitments to our
ocean
and thank you very much
[Music]
is
uh
so the discussion is going to be
structured into four
stages firstly to protect marine uh
uh ecosystems and for sustainable
development also to fight uh pollution
and plastic
ocean
at the end of
so we need to start
[Applause]
we'll have a very useful date and we can
get going with this treaty in march new
york
to reach an agreement to finalize
a framework for managing the high seas
by the end of the year this is a march
in new york
so a minister will be present to make
sure
to finally make
the tools available to protect
international uh high seas which are all
too often uh uh unlawful areas so much
is very important we'll come back to
that to be more specific about it as
we're concerned now
and we need to have
an agreement to do away with public
subsidies which contribute to over
fishing and to illegal fishing we must
put an end to this
is that taxpayers monies should not be
used our taxpayers to continue
to
finance actions which we can heavily
condemn and this will be an opportunity
to be the first
under the ages of the overseas
main objective to protect biodiversity
we need to continue with because we
can't just have conferences talking
about biodiversity and climate change
and then we come back to trade just do
the opposite
i mean we must put things together
we must bring things we must align the
situation so we want to put an end to
unfair competition i think we'll want to
enter into commitments but in geneva for
this 12th ministerial conference i think
we can go further than that and we can
really lock them in then
we need two
i'm continuing i'm continuing um
we've got the
diversity
we must inscribe in marble we must we
must write it in stone our commitments
to protect uh 30 of maritime areas this
is what we owe the planet
this is an alliance
which we started in january 2021 in
paris in the one planet summit
we need to make sure that the maximum
heads of state and government present
now enter into commitment clear pledges
on the protection of our environment
i know that some of you have come with
this will with this determination so we
have got to to extend this to those who
have not yet entered into these pledges
now in lisbon june
president
portugal and kenya
are inviting us to put together science
and innovation to be able to speed up
the deployment of solutions solutions
which have proved their value uh in
combating ocean degradation
in rome september the
fao phishing committee will provide an
opportunity to
notch it up to ratchet up a state uh uh
uh
in order to determine to underscore our
commitments to fisheries industry and
also
with
the
we will be able to put uh oceans at the
heart of international uh climate change
measures uh firstly using the measures
because ecosystem protect against the
rise of waters but also uh to provide uh
to be able to restore the
oceans to a livable state so we really
have a fantastic and
a first-time solution to be able to deal
with this we've got companies local
elected representatives young people we
do have a huge responsibility it it is
to
decide to act it has been said and
that's why i'm not going to say any more
i just want to say i've provided the
menu for the year if you like it
if we make resources available to do
this we're able to take historical
decisions but start today embraced we
need to enter into very clear
commitments as far as we can to be very
clear
our commitments and pledges this is 2022
our oceans can no longer wait we need to
act ladies and gentlemen that's it
[Applause]
to come up to
the podium to give a message
[Music]
[Applause]
excellencies
the foundation of european literature
the iliad
talks about the ocean as the river where
all things are born
it reminds us no matter where we live on
earth
we're all connected by the sea
it is our planet's life support system
as we've just heard every second breath
we take comes from the ocean
it gives us half of the oxygen we
breathe
it absorbs much of the carbon
we throw into the atmosphere
our entire climate depends on the ocean
we have mild winters here in europe
because the ocean pumps millions of tons
of warm water every second from southern
latitudes towards us
the ocean is life
the ocean is nourishment it is energy
and it is jobs
ninety percent of traded goods are
carried by the waves
and for thousands of years the ocean has
been a source of inspiration for art
and a source of longing in literature
for ancient greeks ancient greeks like
homer
the ocean was an almighty god well
i think today we would say
the ocean is part of who we are
but
today this ocean is in danger
pollution
chemicals
plastic waste
over exploitation
you name it and you know it
the ocean is too large for any one of us
and yet so fragile
thus every individual action matters
and this is what brings us here today
it is time indeed for an alliance
it is time for an alliance between us
and the ocean
and therefore as you said mr president
today the european union and the french
presidency of the council are launching
the high ambition coalition on the high
seas for a coalition for adaptation
still this year of the high seas treaty
we need it now
we're so close but we really have to
push to finish it this year
only together we will be able to turn
the tide
i'll give you an example take the ross
scene antarctica
it is today the refuge for whales seals
penguins fish
but only because in 2016 the united
states china russia the european union
and others were able to overcome their
differences and join forces to protect
the area
we can do it again
my second point is we need a mission
like the european green deal
and this is why we have launched the
mission
to restore our ocean and waters by 2030.
we will fund it with half a billion
euros
the mission will focus on europe's five
c's
for example in the mediterranean our
mission is to prevent and eliminate
pollution
in particular plastic and chemical
pollution
or take the baltic and the north north
sea their mission is to decarbonize
shipping and electrify ports
tangible results tangible actions
the ocean missions will bring to market
innovative solutions to regenerate our
ocean
yes it is a european mission
but it is open to all who are
connected by the sea and who want to
contribute
in the black sea for instance we are
already working with all coastal states
because the actions of one
matters to all sharing the waters
all solutions must be shared solutions
and this as we've just heard by a
scientist
is the power of science diplomacy and
its unique potential to overcome
difference
so let us use the moment today and make
it real to have this mission started
let the magic of science diplomacy be
working so that we join forces that
should be a result today too
and finally
the ocean is still a great mystery for
humankind we've just heard it too
we need to better understand its secrets
and this is why europe is building a
digital twin
of the ocean
we are con connecting all our assets
like the copernicus satellites
with icebreakers
boys underwater drones and high
performance performance computing
we will gather the raw materials and the
raw data
we will turn it into real-time knowledge
and then develop longer-term predictions
we are putting the power of the digital
revolution
at the service of our oceans and
eventual our climate
sounds a bit strange i know
but let me give you an example
glaciers in the south and north poles
are melting fast glaciers the size of
entire countries
and this is raising water levels
threatening the existence of small
island states and coastal cities
that part we all know
but there's more
it is also changing the current
that circles the antarctic
the world's largest current and a
decisive regulator of our climate
and it brings deep waters to the surface
which should on one hand have a cooling
effect but on the other hand is also
releasing more carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere
so we need to better understand these
processes and their impact
we need to better understand
in order to better protect
and that's what a digital twin of the
ocean will do and much much more
the digital twin concretely will be
operational by
2020
that's the date we've set ourselves it
will make ocean knowledge open access
available to citizens scientists policy
makers all around the world
it will be a platform for global
cooperation
and it is about tangible tools to
achieve the commitments we make here
today at this summit
ladies and gentlemen
the ocean is immense restless and wild
and when we stand by the coast
we feel humble
small
and in awe
but as we gather here together in breast
we should realize the great power
and the great responsibility we have as
humankind for the next generation so
don't think small think big because our
mission is as big as the ocean many
thanks
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
president
i propose that we continue with these
commitments that you have
so well inaugurated
we would like to now invite mrs samia
sulu president of tanzania
the president of ghana
the head of the
moroccan government
mr aziz akanov
who's not a head of state however she is
an ocean lover and a navigator
i am
cobble
some people think i'm just a rock
when in fact
i'm the largest thing alive on this
planet
but for how long
i grew for almost 250 million years
then humans came along and now one fifth
of me
is gone
but you do need me
do you realize
that one quarter
from the big fish
so i can't live here anymore
here's a crazy thought
stop killing me
nature doesn't need people
people need nature
[Music]
it's also going to join us
for
this
moment of sharing
ideas ideas
samir sulu president of tanzania first
thank you for the questions and
i'm really appreciative being here
attending the
yeah attending the
conference on
how we are going to govern our oceans
and
i've been hearing the word governess
but then i have been hearing
the good governor